[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend am Ende mussten die Chefs
ran nachdem die Fraktionsvorsitzenden
der ampelparteien bis heute morgen um
drei noch mal über das heizungsgesetz
verhandelt und sich wieder nicht
geeinigt hatten schalteten sich am
Mittag der Bundeskanzler
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck und
Finanzminister Lindner in die Gespräche
ein der Kompromiss den sie fanden lautet
wir haben ein Gesetz zum Heizungstausch
aber liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger machen
Sie sich keine Sorgen es gibt ganz viele
Ausnahmen ab dem
1.1.2024 sollen erstmal nur Heizungen in
Neubauten betroffen sein Nicole Diekmann
berichtet aus Berlin
am frühen Abend läuft der Tag des
Kanzlers wieder ganz nach Plan läuft das
aus das Schiff zur alljährlichen
spargelfahrt des Seeheimer Kreises der
konservativen Strömung der SPD mit an
Bord der Bundesfinanzminister FDP und
der bundeslandwirtschaftsminister von
den Grünen die Ampel steht auf
harmonisch nach erheblichen Turbulenzen
nur wenige Stunden zuvor
im Winter müssen wir unser Häuser heizen
und das wird auch anders werden so Stück
für Stück was die Frage betrifft wie wir
das machen deshalb
ruckelt es ein bisschen aber heute hat
es sich glaube ich zu Ende geruckelt der
Kanzler am Mittag im Reichstag ebenso
der Finanzminister sowie der
Wirtschaftsminister außerplanmäßig zu
Hilfe gerufen vom SPD-Fraktionschef das
ist mehr als ein bisschen ruckeln das
ist stürmischer politischer Wellengang
am Morgen hatte Robert Habeck die
Handlungsfähigkeit der Ampel in Frage
gestellt und sie an die Einigung über
sein zentrales Projekt dieser Legislatur
geknüpft
da geht es jetzt inzwischen dann auch
mehr als nur um dieses Wärmegesetz
sondern die Regierung sollte jetzt schon
ihre Regierungsfähigkeit in der Beweis
stellen
nach ihren Beratungen wieder auf zur
Pressekonferenz und um ein Signal zu
senden Mission geglückt
wir werden dieses Gesetz stärker
verzahnen mit der kommunalen
wärmeplanung das Gesetz tritt zum ersten
ersten 2024 in Kraft für alle Heizungen
aber diejenigen die sich entscheiden
nach dem ersten 24 eine neue Heizung
einzubauen und die kommunale
wärmeplanung liegt noch nicht vor den
ermöglichen wir eine Entscheidungszeit
die technologieoffenheit ist in den
Leitplanken die wir vereinbart haben
vollumfänglich gewährleistet ab dem
ersten ersten 24 können auch nach wie
vor beispielsweise Gasheizung verbaut
werden was gut und richtig ist es müssen
Gasheizung sein die beim Zukunft auch
wasserstofffähig sind der wochenlange
erbitterte Streit angeblich ausgeräumt
diesen Eindruck wollten sie erwecken
dass das heizungsgesetz erst zur
Chefsache gemacht werden musste um die
Koalition wieder auf Kurs zu bringen
diesen entscheidenden Punkt vermochten
sie allerdings nur leidlich zur
umschiffen natürlich haben wir die
Regierung hier ins Parlaments gebeten
das war aber auch für die drei nicht so
schwer gewesen die sind auch
gleichzeitig Mitglied ihrer Fraktionen
und wir wussten dass sie an den
Fraktionssitzungen teilnehmen so haben
wir dessen deren Terminkalender auch
nicht durcheinander gebracht
es war ein Tag voll mit den üblichen
Ritualen der betreuerung dass die
Regierung nun in ruhigere Fahrwasser
komme und dem Ringen darum wer politisch
auf dem Sonnendeck steht und es war ein
Tag mit einer ebenfalls fast schon
traditionellen Frage wie lange hält die
Ruhe diesmal
ja wie lange hält die Ruhe diesmal
zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP Christian
dürr der das heizungsgesetz für seine
Partei mit verhandelt hat guten Abend
hätte guten Abend Frau Gellinek sie
haben heute am frühen Abend bei der
Pressekonferenz im Reichstag ein sehr
zufriedenen Eindruck gemacht dabei
hatten sie ja am Mittag noch
festgestellt dass das Gesetz sich
fundamental ändern müssen was hat sich
denn in den Stunden dazwischen verändert
ja es hat sich fundamental geändert und
die Menschen hatten ja sorgen
beispielsweise das Eingriffe in Eigentum
drohte das haben wir abgewendet das
kommt alles nicht der Staat geht selbst
in Vorleistung bevor er den Bürgern
irgendwas abverlangt und vor allen
Dingen es gibt die technologieoffenheit
das war mir besonders wichtig dass die
Heizung zum Haus passt und nicht
umgekehrt ist die Menschen keine Sorgen
haben müssen dass über bordende
Investitionen notwendig werden und das
Gesetz zu erfüllen das kommt alles nicht
beispielsweise können auch in Zukunft
Gasheizung moderne gastheizung eingebaut
werden Holzheizung können eingebaut
werden also es ist ein wirklich
Technologie ohne Ansatz jetzt aber das
wichtigste ist ja glaube ich dass sie in
der Pressekonferenz gesagt haben das
Gesetz greife erst wenn die wärmeplanung
der Kommunen abgeschlossen ist also
ungefähr ab 2028 feiern sie es als
Erfolg das Gesetz jetzt möglichst weit
nach hinten rausgeschoben zu haben nein
darum geht es nicht aber es wäre ja
geradezu absurd wenn man die Bürgern was
abverlangt bevor der Staat geleistet hat
also ab 2028 etwa wird es kommunale
wärmeplanung in Deutschland geben das
ist auch sinnvoll weil wir klimaneutral
werden wollen und deswegen braucht es ja
auch eine Überarbeitung dieses Gesetzes
es gibt ja ein Vorläufer der großen
Koalition und das hätte nicht
funktioniert die Menschen werden mit CO2
Kosten mit hohen CO2 Kosten alleine
geblieben und deswegen wollten wir ein
neues Gesetz allerdings nicht den ersten
Ansatz von Robert Habeck und jetzt haben
wir uns geeinigt dass wir das Gesetz da
noch mal fundamental ändern werden das
ist gut wir stellen es quasi vom Kopf
auf die Füße und die Menschen können
wirklich sicher sein dass alle
Technologien genutzt werden können also
da passt die Heizung wirklich zum Haus
und das ist ein sehr sehr gutes Ergebnis
vom Kopf auf die Füße aber was heißt das
für den Klimaschutz denn darum geht es
ja eigentlich es geht ja eigentlich
darum die Emissionen zu verringern ja
sehen sie da ist die Wärmepumpe aber
nicht die einzige Antwort die kann auch
sehr teuer sein im Einzelfall gerade in
Bestandsgebäuden sondern beispielsweise
Gasheizung nicht erwähnte das von die in
Zukunft klimaneutral durch Wasserstoff
betrieben werden können das ist die
technologieoffenheit oder Holzheizung
die ja auch klimaneutral sind weil sie
nachwachsende Rohstoffe nutzen also der
Klimaanlage ne ja aber die brauchen ja
den Hochlauf ohnehin für die deutsche
Industrie insgesamt aber Sie sollten die
Wasserstoff Netze weiter nutzen denn es
wird nicht alles aus heimischer Sonne
und heimischen Wind produziert werden
können es gibt ja teilweise die
Situation das Wärmepumpen gar nicht
angeschlossen werden können weil es die
Netze nicht hergeben und wir haben die
ganzen Netze die sollten wir
klimaneutral bekommen und dann hat jeder
Haushalt auch eine kostengünstige Lösung
und dass wir uns darauf einigen konnten
das freut mich wirklich sehr weil wir
die Technologie von Anfang an wichtig
war die FDP hat offenbar bei diesem
heizungsgesetz jetzt gewonnen aber sie
haben Freunde in der Regierung besonders
bei den Grünen verloren wie wollen sie
eigentlich auf dieser Grundlage weitere
gehen in der Ampel das die Einschätzung
teile ich nicht Frau Gellinek denn
Robert Habeck hat ja in den letzten
Wochen selbst gesagt es müsse Änderung
geben und auch deutliche Änderungen er
sprach auch von technologieoffenheit es
freut mich das war uns da gegenseitig
überzeugen konnten und wir als FDP
vielleicht auch ein bisschen ihn und das
ist ja auch ein gutes parlamentarisches
Verfahren dass man miteinander spricht
und sagt wir müssen das anders machen
ich hätte mir von Anfang an vielleicht
noch anders gewünscht aber jetzt haben
wir ein wirklich gutes Ergebnis jetzt
reden wir im Parlament über die Details
aber diese Grundsatzentscheidung
Technologie auf dem Hals das wird nicht
jetzt Eigentum eingegriffen das ist
wirklich richtig gut und eine gute
Botschaft für die Menschen in
Deutschland Ampel Frieden aus FDP sich
sagt Christian dürr
Fraktionsvorsitzender der FDP herzlichen
Dank für das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
und das Interview haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet und wir gehen
direkt noch mal nach Berlin dort wo uns
jetzt der Vizekanzler und
Wirtschaftsminister von den Grünen
zugeschaltet ist guten Abend weg grüße
Sie Ihre Fraktionschefin Katharina dröge
hat sich am Abend sehr artig bedankt
dafür dass ihr Gesetz jetzt doch noch
besser geworden sei klingt da die
Einsicht durch dass der erste Entwurf
wirklich war
das wäre ja sehr erstaunlich weil ja die
FDP und die SPD die mitgetragen haben
nein es war ein ambitioniertes Gesetz
aber es hat sich etwas verändert und das
erklärt warum wir jetzt noch mal die
Vorzeichen ein bisschen
justiert haben
als für dieses Kind die FDP hat
zugestimmt dass es eine verpflichtende
kommunale wärmeplanung geben soll das
war am Anfang des Jahres nicht der Fall
das heißt wir waren mit diesem Gebäude
Energiegesetz zum heizgesetz quasi
alleine in der Rechtsordnung jetzt gibt
es eine verpflichten oder es soll eine
verpflichtende kommunale wärmeplanung
geben wir reden noch ein bisschen
darüber welche Kommunen ab wann das
machen müssen oder bis wann die das
machen müssen aber das ist natürlich ein
ganz anderer Ansatz und deswegen haben
wir den Kern des Gesetzes behalten aber
den Zugang an das gewählt ich will das
kurz ausführen in dem alten
Gesetzentwurf stand drin wenn eine
Heizung kaputt geht und nur um die ging
es ja immer dann hast du drei Jahre Zeit
jetzt überlegen was du machen willst in
diesen drei Jahren kannst du auch eine
verschiedene Gasheizung noch mal
einbauen und dann musst du diese Vorgabe
65% erneuerbare Wärme haben jetzt sagen
wir du musst die kommunale wärmeplanung
abwarten und dann sich entscheiden und
das macht der Sinn die kommunale
wärmeplanung wiederum ist sehr
unterschiedlich große Städte haben die
teilweise schon sehr viele Bundesländer
sind weit vorgegangen und werden Sie im
nächsten Jahr abschließen und andere
brauchen ein bisschen länger aber mit
dieser Gleitphase ersetzen wir quasi
diese drei Jahre und das ist etwas was
ich Christian gerade angesprochen selber
vorgeschlagen habe also insofern alles
in Ordnung also nicht die FDP hat die
Grünen überzeugt sondern sie haben die
FDP überzeugt sagen sie die FDP hat aber
heute ja verkündet dass wegen dieser
Verzahnung die Sie gerade angesprochen
haben mit der kommunalen wärmeplanung
das Gesetz ja erst 2028 kommt für die
Bestandsbauten das heißt nimmerleinstag
ich will einmal sagen diese Kategorien
von Sieg oder Niederlage die muss man
natürlich fragen das verstehe ich schon
aber sie verhindern natürlich jeden
Kompromiss und das was heute gelungen
ist neben den fachlichen Details ich
beantworte gerne Ihre Frage ist ja vor
allem die Handlungsfähigkeit der
Regierung und damit auch das
Zusammenrücken des Landes wieder zu
ermöglichen diese Debatte drohte ja zu
einem endlos eine Endlosschleife zu
werden und das ist dann verhindert
worden weil wir uns mal kurz frei
gemacht haben von wer hat gewonnen wer
hat verloren und das ist auch das
richtige der richtige Zugang zu
politischen Debatten nein gar nicht man
sucht einen gemeinsamen Weg man macht
die Quadratur des Kreises dass man
tauscht die Argumente aus die FDP hat
die verpflichtende Werbeplanung
zugegeben damit den Weg noch mal neu
eröffnet wir haben das aufgenommen
hier sind alle gleich klug und keiner
hat so richtig nachgegeben oder alle
haben ein bisschen nachgegeben und so
ist auch gut so was die 28 angeht das
ist das Enddatum wann eine kommunale
wärmeplanung abgeschlossen sein soll
insofern ja es wird einige Kommunen
geben die bis 28 brauchen andere
Bundesländer haben ja schon früher
verpflichtende kommunale wärmeplanung
aufgelegt die sind dann schon teilweise
24 oder dann 25 26 fertig und so gleiten
wir mit großen Mengen der Bevölkerung
Schritt für Schritt in das Gesetz rein
und das ist klug weil damit eine Antwort
auf die Frage oder auf die Sorge gegeben
wurde haben wir überhaupt genug
Handwerker gibt es genug Wärmepumpen und
so weiter also insofern ist die 28 das
Enddatum aber es heißt nicht dass jetzt
bis 28 gar nicht passiert sondern
Schritt für Schritt wird dieses Ziel
erreicht aber Fakt ist ja schon dass das
Gesetz ganz anders jetzt in einer ganz
anderen Form herausgekommen ist als es
reingegangen ist in diesem
Verhandlungsprozess er hat sie hätten ja
eigentlich alle Chancen gehabt nachdem
Putin das Gas abgedreht hat diese
Energiewende zu einer riesen
Erfolgsgeschichte für die Ampel zu
machen was war rückblickend nach dem
ganzen Knatsch nach den 77 Fragen der
FDP was war der dickste Fehler den sie
gemacht haben
ich denke dass die der Übergang also
jetzt wenn sie mich persönlich fragen
der Übergang von der Phase um
Weihnachten herum zu der Phase wo das
erneuerbare dieses GEG das Gebäude
Energiegesetz vorgestellt wurde eine
politische Veränderung durchlaufen hat
ich kann mich daran erinnern wir haben
kurz vor Weihnachten auf der
europäischen Ebene ein Mechanismus
vereinbart der den Gaspreis Decken
Deckeln sollte und ich hielte das für
verheiratet habe dass wir falsch
gehalten weil ich große Sorge hatte dass
wir eine gasmangelage bekommen und
damals also war die Furcht real dass wir
zu viel Gas in Deutschland verbrauchen
und jede Gasheizung die neu eingebaut
werden würde hätte das Problem
vergrößert das war der Arbeitsauftrag
mit dem wir gestartet sind und dann hat
sich die Lage schnell entspannt die
Verbräuche sind zurückgegangen der
Gaspreis ist runtergegangen ist kam
genug Gas nach Deutschland so dass als
das Gesetz dann kam die öffentliche
Meinung gar nicht mehr in diesem Krisen
oder angstmodus war so gut wie kriegen
wir die gasverbräuche runter sondern oje
da will jemand jetzt sozusagen in mein
gewohntes Umfeld rein und dazwischen
Grund für das Gesetz ist ja die Senkung
der Emissionen nicht die Senkung des
gasverbrauches dann die Senkung der
CO2-Ausstoßes jein denn natürlich das
ist der Sinn dieses Gesetzes insgesamt
aber das wir es vorgezogen haben also
auf den ersten 24 für einen Auftrag des
Koalitionsausschusses aus der
Energiekrise heraus das war der gleiche
Auftrag der gesagt hat wir müssen die
die Abgaben auf Gas reduzieren weil die
Preise zu hoch sind die damals den Tank
Rabatt eingeführt haben also das
Vorziehen war eine unmittelbare Reaktion
auf die russland-krise so zwischen
diesen Weihnachtstagen in Europa als ich
wirklich Angst hatte dass ich die
Versorgung Sicherheit in Deutschland
nicht mehr gewähren kann und dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz liegen nur wenige Wochen
und in diesen wenigen Wochen hat sich
etwas verändert und das habe ich nicht
die Fragen ja nach meinem Fehler das
habe ich nicht
rechtzeitig gespürt oder analysiert
haben sie mal dran gedacht
hinzuschmeißen während dieser ganzen
Krise ganz kurze Antwort nein überhaupt
nicht die ganzen Gegenteil sagt der
Vizekanzler und Wirtschaftsminister von
den Grünen herzlichen Dank danke nach
Berlin
und später im heute-journal Update gibt
es noch ein Gespräch mit Jens Spahn dem
Vize-Chef der Unionsfraktion
bei allem Streit um das Gebäude
Energiegesetz eins ist in der
ampelregierung Konsens seit Putin
Deutschland das Gas abgedreht hat hat
der Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
absoluten Vorrang und zwar am liebsten
in Europa gerade erst versucht die
Solarindustrie hier wieder Fuß zu fassen
zum Beispiel in Sachsen-Anhalt hier
betreibt die Schweizer Firma Meyer
Burger eine Fertigungshalle für
Solarzellen erst letzten Juli kam
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck zu Besuch um
das Comeback der Branche zu feiern
vielleicht zu früh gefreut wenn die USA
locken mit einem massiven
Investitionsprogramm ein Angebot das
Meyer Bürger vielleicht nicht ablehnen
kann Florian neuhahn berichtet
was man hier sieht das ist einzigartig
nicht auf der Welt nein aber in der EU
hier nämlich werden Solarzellen
produziert die kleinen Bauteile aus
denen jedes Solarmodul besteht fast alle
dieser Solarzellen kommen mittlerweile
aus China hier in Talheim Sachsen-Anhalt
aber steht das einzige solarzellenwerk
in Europa bis 2027 wollte die Firma
Meyer Burger ihre Kapazitäten hier
verzehnfachen das war der Plan
doch in einem Brief an das
Bundesfinanzministerium der dem ZDF
exklusiv vorliegt heißt es man erwege
diese Projekte in die USA zu verlagern
passende Gebäudekomplexe haben wir schon
gefunden in den USA erklärt der
Vorstandschef werde Solarfirmen der rote
Teppich ausgerollt wenn Sie heute in die
USA gehen mit einer
Solarzellenproduktion dann bekommen sie
Steuergutschriften in bar ausgezahlt
wenn man ein Gigawatt Solarzellen und
Solarmodule in den USA produziert erhält
man pro Jahr 110 Millionen Dollar das
Geld kommt aus dem
mega-investitionsprogramm der USA dem
Inflation reduction Act mit dem der
US-Präsident grüne Technologien lockt
gefördert wird nur wer auch dort
produziert
und Europa im Frühjahr noch hatte die
EU-Kommission dass ehrgeizige Ziel
ausgegeben bis 2030 sollen 40% der
Zukunftstechnologien aus europäischer
Produktion stammen man will unabhängig
werden von China wenn jetzt der einzige
Solarzellenhersteller seinen Ausbau
stoppt es wäre ein herber Rückschlag
ich glaube der Staat muss damit helfen
wir können es uns nicht leisten in
Europa dass alle unsere Industrie die
wir brauchen abwandert es ist das
globale Rennen um die Energieform der
Zukunft hier der Billiganbieter China da
die Millionen aus den USA kann Europa
mithalten oder wird es hier erpresst
natürlich das Risiko besteht das
Unternehmen
Regierungen ausspielen Regierung in
Europa und und Amerika und hier
versuchen Fördermittel abzugreifen aber
dennoch ich denke in diesen strategisch
wichtigen Sektoren ist ist richtig das
ist Risiko einzugehen die Dominanz die
china hat in diesen Technologien und die
Abhängigkeit die wir haben müssen wir
verringern auch wenn das mit einem Preis
kommt der Preis das wären Subventionen
aus dem deutschen Haushalt das
Finanzministerium in Berlin will das
Schreiben von Meyer Bürger heute nicht
kommentieren die Firma selbst sagt noch
habe sie nicht entschieden wo sie
künftig investiert
und wir machen weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Gundula Gause und die
beginnen mit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine Russland
hat den Raketenbeschuss mehrere Regionen
in der Ukraine massiv fortgesetzt
getroffen wurde auch die Heimat des
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski viele
Marschflugkörper habe die
Luftverteidigung abwehren können
erklärte das ukrainische Militär in
silenskis Heimatstadt Ribery aber wurde
ein fünfstöckiges Wohnhaus getroffen
mindestens elf Menschen wurden getötet
28 verletzt Kreml Chef Putin forderte in
einem Fernsehgespräch erneut den Stock
der Waffenlieferungen des Westens an die
Ukraine das sei der einzige Weg den
Konflikt zu beenden zugleich bestritt
Putin Erfolge der ukrainischen gegen
Offensive
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg hat
unterdessen in Washington erklärt dass
die Ukraine bei ihrer Offensive
Fortschritte mache je mehr Land die
Ukrainer befreien könnten desto stärker
werde ihre Position am Verhandlungstisch
sein nur so werde Putin begreifen dass
er so wörtlich diese Schlacht nie und
nimmer gewinnen werde
gegenüber US-Präsident beiden sagte
Stoltenberg aber auch die ukrainische
Armee sei erst am Anfang ihrer gegen
Offensive beim nächsten naturgipfel in
Litauen Mitte Juli solle es um weitere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine gehen
in der Diskussion über gesetzliche
Regelungen zur Sterbehilfe haben zwei
abgeordnetengruppen einen gemeinsamen
Entwurf vorgestellt demnach soll jeder
das Recht auf Hilfe zur Selbsttötung
haben entscheidend der Entschluss dazu
müsse aus freiem Willen Erfolgen im
Gegensatz zu einem anderen Entwurf sieht
dieser Kompromiss keine Sanktionierung
per Strafrecht vor
ausschließlich volljährige sollen Zugang
zu Medikamenten zur Selbsttötung
bekommen Voraussetzung eine kostenlose
und ergebnisoffene fachliche Beratung
und eine Bedenkzeit von mindestens drei
Wochen
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
einen hitzeschutzplan angekündigt nach
französischen Vorbild will er je nach
Schwere einer Hitzewelle Schutzmaßnahmen
definieren etwa kälteräume
Aktionspläne für Pflegeeinrichtungen und
Anrufe bei älteren um diese ans
regelmäßige Trinken zu erinnern für die
Umsetzung wären Länder und Kommunen
zuständig im vergangenen Jahr soll es
4.500 hitzebedingte Sterbefälle gegeben
haben
nach wochenlanger Hitze und starker
Trockenheit nehmen die Waldbrände in
Deutschland zu im Südwesten
Mecklenburg-Vorpommerns kämpfen hunderte
Feuerwehrleute gegen zwei große
Waldbrände betroffen sind ehemalige
Militärgelände im Boden liegt noch viel
Munition die sich entzündet und in
vielen Fällen detoniert der nahegelegene
Ort vollsrat wurde evakuiert
Ministerpräsidentin Schwesig erklärte es
sei bedrückend dass die Gegend 4 Jahre
nach einem massiven Feuer wieder von
Waldbränden bedroht sein
dieses Urteil des Landgerichts Köln wird
Rechtsgeschichte schreiben ein
Präzedenzfall der die katholische Kirche
mit einer Welle von Schmerzensgeld und
Entschädigungsforderungen überfluten
könnte jahrelang war der Kläger als
Junge von einem Priester vergewaltigt
worden doch die Kirche als Institution
zu verklagen das konnte er sich nicht
vorstellen jetzt tat er es doch und
bekam Recht das Erzbistum Köln muss
300.000 Euro Schmerzensgeld zahlen weil
es den jungen nicht vor dem Täter
schützte sarattacke und Michael
haselrieder berichten
er hat ein Urteil erstritten dass es so
noch nie gab Georg Männer sein Gegner
die mächtige katholische Kirche das
Erzbistum Köln vertreten nur durch seine
Anwälte durch das von ihm erstrittene
Urteil ist jetzt erstmals klar die
Kirche haftet als Institution für
Missbrauch durch ihre Priester ein
Meilenstein für alle Missbrauchsopfer
ich bin erstmal froh ein Stück das mir
Gerechtigkeit wiederfährt und wie mit
zwei betroffen und
Opfer auch gesagt haben sie sind froh
dass ich das ausgehalten habe denn das
was ihm vor 50 Jahren angetan wurde
belastet ihn bis heute in dieser Kirche
im Erzbistum Köln war Georg meine
Messdiener mehr als sieben Jahre lang
missbrauchte ihn ein katholischer
Priester
also wir reden jetzt hier davon dass
seit 1973 fast täglich wenn ich in der
Eifel war sich an mir vergangen hat und
das was sie sich praktisch auf Fantasie
mäßig in allen Variationen vorstellen
können ist auch passiert
Georg Menne war damals 13 Jahre alt hier
fotografiert von seinem Peiniger was ihm
angetan wurde kann mit Geld nicht
aufgewogen werden und trotzdem macht
Georg Menne seinen Missbrauch öffentlich
verklagt die katholische Kirche um Geld
und Gerechtigkeit für ihn und ein Signal
der Justiz für alle Missbrauchsopfer zu
erwirken es ist ein Meilenstein heute
dieses Urteil sowohl in der Höhe 300.000
Euro als auch mit der Tatsache dass zum
ersten Mal ein Gericht klargestellt hat
dass die katholische Kirche für die
Verbrechen ihrer Priester und für das
vertuschungssystem dass die Kirche über
Jahrzehnte betrieben hat haftet denn das
Bistum Köln mit Kardinal Wölki an der
Spitze weigerte sich bis jetzt
Schmerzensgeld zu zahlen überwies Georg
Männer nur 25.000 Euro freiwillig als
Anerkennung des Leids so umging die
Kirche bis heute ein rechtliches
Eingeständnis ihrer Schuld
wir haben in unserem kirchlichen Kontext
bisher ein eigenes Verfahren und in
diesem Verfahren zur Anerkennung des
leits haben die Bischöfe ein eigenes
Verfahren festgelegt und dieses
Verfahren ist heute natürlich noch mal
ergänzt worden ergänzt um
275.000 Euro die die Kirche Georg Menne
jetzt zahlen muss das zeigt die
kirchliche Anerkennung des Leids hat
schlicht dem geltenden Recht nicht
genügt wir müssen jetzt schauen ob wir
wirklich tausende von Missbrauchsopfern
vor die Gerichte schicken wollen in der
ganzen Republik oder ob es doch noch mal
einen Anlauf gibt in Richtung einer
Verhandlungslösung und wir werden
schauen ob das Gericht möglicherweise
die Kompromissbereitschaft auf Seiten
der Bischöfe erhöht hat noch können zwar
beide Seiten des Urteil anfechten aber
die Signalwirkung die bleibt
die geheimen Papiere lagerten in Kisten
auf der Bühne des Ballsaals in Donald
Trumps Schlafzimmer und in der Dusche
seines Anwesens in Mara Lago die Akten
gaben Aufschluss über die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der USA und
potenzielle Militäraktionen Donald Trump
hatte hunderte solcher Geheimdokumente
aus dem Weißen Haus mitgenommen und wird
nun wegen Aufbewahrung höchst sensibler
Informationen in Miami angeklagt und wie
immer bei Trump ist es eine riesen Show
Claudia Beetz ist für uns in Miami
Claudia was bedeutet diese Anklage für
Trump und seine Chancen erneut
US-Präsident zu werden
ja hier in Miami ist in der Tat auch vor
dem Gericht der große tram-zirkus wieder
in Aktion allerdings sind viel weniger
Menschen gekommen als Trumps sich das
nach seinen aufrufen hierher zu kommen
wohl erwartet hatte
unabhängige Juristen und auch
republikanische Juristen halten die
Anklage ja für sehr stichhaltig aber
Trumps narrativ ist natürlich die
demokrateninstrumentalisieren die Justiz
um ihren wichtigsten und gefährlichsten
gegen Kandidaten auszuschalten bei den
innerparteilichen Vorwahlen innerhalb
der republikanischen Partei könnte das
verfangen und könnte Trump tatsächlich
zur Kandidatur verhelfen aber dann wird
es ja darum gehen die Wähler der Mitte
die Konservativen moderaten Wähler zu
überzeugen und das dürfte ihm mit einer
so schwerwiegenden Anklage und mit dem
Trump Zirkus den viele auch einfach leid
sind nicht gelingen und die wird er
brauchen zur präsidentschaftskandidiert
zur Präsidentschaftswahl
okay vielen dank Claudia nach Miami und
wir machen weiter mit Nachrichten und
noch einmal in Gundula mit Themen die
direkt unser aller Geldbeutel betreffen
die Inflationsrate in Deutschland hat
sich im Mai weiter abgeschwächt bleibt
aber auf hohem Niveau laut Statistischen
Bundesamt lag die Teuerung bei 6,1
Prozent im Jahresvergleich nach noch
über sieben Prozent im April Valerie
Halle nach wie vor teuer bleiben
Nahrungsmittel sie sind aktuell sogar
Preis Treiber Nummer eins was natürlich
eine besonders große Belastung ist für
Menschen mit geringem Einkommen aber
insgesamt sagen Verbraucher Schützer
sparen viele Menschen inzwischen in
praktisch allen Bereichen vom
Energieverbrauch über Restaurantbesuche
bis zum Reisen und eben auch beim Essen
denn tatsächlich sind Lebensmittel im
Mai deutlich teurer geworden um fast 15%
im Vergleich zum Vorjahr immerhin die
hohen Inflationsraten sind auf dem
Rückzug schon dritten Monat in Folge was
darauf hindeutet dass der Höhepunkt der
Inflation wohl überschritten ist bis zum
Jahresende dürfte der Preisauftrieb also
weiter spürbar nachlassen ja auch in den
USA geht die Inflation zurück und zwar
deutlich auf glatt 4 Prozent da scheint
sich der Trend zu festigen ja die
amerikanische Notenbank wird das
vermutlich als etappensiebter Sieg
verbuchen nach 10 Zinserhöhungen die
etwas niedrigere Inflationsrate dürfte
ihr aber auch Spielraum geben in ihrer
morgigen Sitzung eine Zinspause
einzulegen an der Wall Street rechnen
viele damit ja und diese Woche
Donnerstag tagt auch die Europäische
Zentralbank die allerdings dürfte die
Zinsen ein weiteres Mal anheben alles
andere wäre eine Überraschung wir werden
sehen und Berichten vielen Dank Valerie
an die Börse
den gesetzlichen Krankenkassen droht im
kommenden Jahr erneut eine Finanzlücke
in Milliardenhöhe wegen zugleich
steigender Ausgaben müssten die
Versicherten mit höheren Beitragssätzen
rechnen erklärte Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach nach Angaben der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherungen kann sich das
Defizit auf bis zu 7 Milliarden Euro
gelaufen das Bundesverwaltungsgericht
hat eine kräftige Gebührenerhöhung für
das Anwohnerparken in Freiburg gekippt
das Urteil gilt als Signal für andere
Kommunen geklagt hatte ein Freiburger
Stadtrat der FDP nach dem Ende 2021 die
Gebühren für das Anwohnerparken von 30
auf mindestens 360 € pro Jahr erhöht
worden waren für den Kläger eine
unzumutbare Belastung viele Bürger das
Gericht kritisierte die Form der
Neuregelung hat aber keine
grundsätzlichen Einwände gegen die
Erhöhung
und das war es von uns wir empfehlen
Ihnen jetzt sehr die 37 Grad Reportage
unter dem Titel jung begabt und seelisch
krank jeder fünfte Jugendliche so die
erschreckende Bilanz braucht
professionelle Hilfe Tendenz steigend
und um 0 Uhr meldet sich nazanökte mir
also mit unserem heute journal Update
und morgen erwarten Sie hier Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali Ihnen einen
schönen Abend und tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend der Regen der bei uns fehlt
fällt zurzeit am Mittelmeer heute gab es
schon Unwetter hier am westlichen
Mittelmeer das dazugehörige tief zieht
bis morgen weiter nach Italien bei uns
dominierte gegen immer noch ein hoch und
höchstens ganz wenige Wolken wenige
Schauer kommen von Osten zu uns rein und
so fällt bei uns wirklich kaum Regen und
das bleibt auch noch bis Sonntag so ganz
anders sieht das dagegen am zentralen
Mittelmeer aus da können bis
Sonntagabend durchaus an die 100 Liter
Regen pro Quadratmeter fallen in Irland
20 bis 50 Liter pro Quadratmeter und
östlich von uns 20 bis 80 Liter pro
Quadratmeter heute Nacht ist es meist
klar ein paar kleine wolkenfälle gibt es
im Osten oder es findet sich auch mein
Nebel oder Dunst die Temperaturen sinken
auf 16 Grad am Niederrhein und bis sechs
Grad am Rad und morgen geht's wieder
viel Sonnenschein im Südwesten aber auch
an den Küsten sonst aber doch deutlich
mehr Quellwolken als noch heute und auch
morgen könnte es hier im Erzgebirge auch
im südlichen Brandenburg mal für einen
kleinen Regenschauer oder ein kurzes
Gewitter reichen bei Wind aus
nordöstlichen Richtung die Temperaturen
steigen morgen in der Osthälfte auf 19
bis 24 im Westen auf 23 bis 28 Grad und
dieses West-Ost Gefälle bei den
Temperaturen sehen wir auch bei den
europatemperaturen so ist es in
Frankreich wärmer als in Polen und den
Ungarn und an unserem Wetter ändert sich
in den nächsten Tagen wenig bei 19 bis
30 Grad guten Abend